well thank you all very much for having
me here I'm super excited this is my
first time to Israel and
I want to start by talking about this
particular quote because this Court has
been around for a long time if you don't
know who Alan Kay is by the way you
should google him and look up the
Wikipedia one of the grandfather's of
what we do in computing science this
Court has often thrown around to suggest
that it is that we can dream big and we
can make whatever the future that we
want to be and so people aspire to go
create all these amazing things we could
say oh well we can just invent whatever
we can dream up we can invent and we can
create that future but I see something
different in this quote and it's the
thing that I want you to keep in the
back of your mind as I talk through
today I see something different in this
quote because what I see is a
responsibility what I see is that the
future that we are going to have the
future that is going to happen a year
from now five years from now ten years
from now fifty years from now is
directly our responsibility the things
that we are doing the choices that we're
making now are going to directly impact
that future and that means that if we
are going to participate in this thing
called building the web we should be
very careful about those decisions to
make sure that we don't create the kind
of future for ourselves and for our kids
and our grandkids we don't want to
create that future if that's not the
future that we want them to have there
is a responsibility we need to be asking
ourselves what direction are we actually
headed in because there's an awful lot
of different futures that are possible
and not all things that we could get to
not all things that we could do are
things that we ought to do so I want you
to keep that in the back of your mind as
I begin to ask some of these questions
this morning I'm going to start with a
brief history lesson but it's going to
be a little bit strange because it's not
what you're expecting this is a brief
and incomplete history lesson of
American spaceflight and credit goes to
a NASA engineer David Hasan he came and
spoke at my son's elementary school and
I took some of the ideas that he had
from his talk to frame the beginning of
my talk today so if you're not familiar
with the history of American spaceflight
it was roughly divided into three basic
phases over the course of the 1960's
over the course of that decade it's
divided into three
phases it started with the mercury
phrase and these were using the Atlas
rockets and if you look here on the left
at the very very top where that tiny red
thing up there at the top is that's
where the the astronaut one astronaut
singular was actually bolted in not like
Oh like we see in the movies where they
can like move around and dance in space
and all of that sort of stuff literally
bolted into his chair and they welded
the door shut that's what it was like in
the most in the earliest version of us
sending a person into space so the
mercury program was all about can we get
somebody into space and get them back
here to earth and they survived that
trip that was essentially the big idea
we laid out this vision that we want to
put somebody on the moon but there's a
whole lot of steps that are gonna be
involved to get us there so what are
those steps going to look like what
steps do we need to do so they divided
the first mission was just can we
successfully put people into space but
what was interesting and this is again
something that I hadn't realized until
David pointed this out what was
interesting is that even during this
particular phase of spaceflight even
though they were really just focused on
this one goal can we get a person into
space they were also already thinking
about what they were going to need in
the next phase so they had an eye both
to the immediate future as well as to
where they were headed and that's a
really important takeaway there is a
tension between are we focused on just
the immediate just shipping something or
are we also focused or at least thinking
about strategically where are we headed
because in the second phase of the space
missions which was called the Gemini
phase they realized something during the
initial phase that was a really big
problem and that was we can't have the
person bolted in that's a really
terrible idea this is super dangerous
this is never gonna work and also by the
way in the first phase they didn't
really want them to participate in that
we didn't think that we could trust
humans to do something like flying a
rocket and so they were basically just
along for the ride the computer did
everything for them and they said now
that's a terrible idea we actually need
to have
be an active part of the mission so in
the Gemini's stages of these rockets
again using a different rock at this
time the titan rockets what they needed
to do was have the astronaut now there
were two astronauts not just one and
they need to actually participate in the
mission so there were buttons and
controls that they actually had to work
with during the flight and they could
move around to an extent within it and
they realized all of these things from
both successes and failures they had in
the first phase but in this particular
phase of flight in the Gemini phase of
the space missions their goal was can we
go outside of the rocket can we like do
spacewalks and can we dock rockets
together so we've made some big progress
from just can we get a man into space so
now can we start doing something useful
while we're in space and they were
already doing experiments during this
phase that would lead them to the third
and final and most famous of the phases
which was the Apollo phases of the space
mission these are the ones that you've
most likely heard of it's the ones they
made movies about like for example
Apollo 11 when Neil Armstrong was the
first man to set foot onto the moon
so this Apollo phase was of course the
finalization let's finally take that
literal last step and actually get onto
the moon but there were a bunch of
things they needed in this phase that
they would not have been able to achieve
here had they not been thinking about
that back during the mercury and Gemini
phases and again it is that idea about
these small steps that have to be made
but also I thought towards the bigger
strategic direction we have to know that
we're headed towards setting foot on the
moon so that we're doing the right
things now the right preparation steps
and the right experiments figuring
things out they had to invent all of
this from scratch
there was no manual there was no book
that told them this is how to get to the
moon and so they couldn't have all of it
planned out but if they didn't have that
strategic vision I don't think we would
have achieved this goal that we set out
to do this in just nine or 10 short
years and so what he points out is that
from that first primitive rocket to
being able to set someone on the moon we
made a lot of progress but we didn't
make giant leaps rather we made lots of
baby steps
then we took lots of tiny little baby
steps we made one decision and we did
one experiment and we made one progress
and then we did a different mission and
we did another thing and this is a lot
like software development that you have
to have this bigger vision but you also
have to take small incremental steps and
the problem that I see a lot in our
industry is that it gets far too easy to
get myopically focused only on the tiny
steps only on what is immediately in
front of us and lose track of that
bigger vision where are we headed we
call this agile by the way agile means I
don't need to worry about where we're
headed we only need to worry about what
ships right now we've codified it into a
whole discipline in practice so I want
you to keep that tension in mind I want
you to be thinking not only about the
baby steps but about the big vision of
where are we headed are we trying to set
foot under the moon now some of you I'm
sure at least most of you have heard
Brendan Ike's famous always bet on
JavaScript and he did this slide at a
conference back in I think 2010 or 2011
I think at a jas coffee he unveiled this
slide and he said you know over the
years everybody has claimed that
javascript was going to reach its final
limitation and not be able to achieve
something that that it was aspiring to
do and so we're gonna eventually
JavaScript's gonna out outlive its
usefulness and be replaced by something
else and there been naysayers that have
said that over the years and they they
first said that javascript couldn't do
the rich internet apps the way regular
native apps were and then they said it
couldn't be fast and they said it
couldn't be fixed and correct and they
said it couldn't do multi-core and it
turns out that every time that people
have bet against JavaScript they've been
wrong the JavaScript has had this
amazing flexibility to it to begin to
grow and evolve and if you think about
where Brendan Eich created JavaScript it
was in this 10-day prototyping phase it
was an experiment and yet today
javascript is the most ubiquitous
language on the planet it's in robots
and refrigerators and TVs and watches
and glasses and light bulbs and every
other kind of device that you can
imagine and there's no possible way that
somebody could have imagined that exact
future nor could they have imagined and
planned out all of the tiny baby steps
that it would take
get there and so there is I think to
some extent some accidental genius
involved that we have a language that
has been so flexible and has been able
to be stretched in all of these various
different directions and so it is
rightly said that if you've been betting
against JavaScript it's been a bad bet
by the way if you're not familiar with
the reference why this is always better
this is Wesley Snipes in a movie called
passenger 51 and he famously in this
movie he says always bet on black so
that's where this comes from always bet
on JavaScript don't bet against
JavaScript okay so that's true we always
want to bet on JavaScript and the talk
today that I'm giving you is called keep
betting on JavaScript so it is a hopeful
forward-looking message that says yes we
should keep betting on JavaScript but it
comes with the caveat that we have to
ask ourselves what is that future
JavaScript that we're betting on up
until this point I would argue that it
has been a rather safe bet it has been a
rather safe bet that if we just keep
betting on it progressing according to
the needs of the industry that things
are going to go okay but I think we have
reached potentially an inflection point
where if we're not careful the future
that we are building is not necessarily
the future that we want so we have to
keep betting on JavaScript but we have
to know where that is headed I want to
talk about another history lesson again
this one is protect perhaps not exactly
what you were expecting I want to talk
about my journey into web programming
and into JavaScript Bruce shared just a
moment ago how he started in 2002 I
started somewhere around that time about
1999 to 2001 somewhere in that range is
when I was getting into the web so I
want to talk to you about my journey
into JavaScript as a matter of fact the
first experience that I had with
anything related to the web was in 1997
ish in high school and we had one
computer in the high school that was
connected to the Internet and it had
like Netscape 2 or Netscape 3 on it
these were the days of Netscape 3 and ie
4 and these were very primitive days
very early days of the web and I
remember reading there like 4 websites
that were in existence at that time we
would go and surf not for any particular
reason but just because this was the
cool new thing you could do
you've got 30 minutes a week
to go sit at this computer and
experience what would be the web and I
wish at that moment that I could have
seen what my career trajectory might be
that I would end up making this a
profession going into figuring out how
to do the web
I couldn't even conceive at the time
that somebody could figure out how to
build that sort of stuff it just existed
and and I didn't even have a mindset to
ask how does it exist how does one
create this and I didn't develop that
curiosity until a couple of years later
when I was in college and I was able to
build a website for one of the student
organizations that I was part of so
that's where my journey started was I
saw the web and then a couple of years
later became curious about well how can
I do something like that how can I build
something like the web and of course the
way I answered that question is the way
most people answered that question I did
view source I clicked on view source to
figure out how they did it and then I
copied it for myself
and it was amazing because the most
important thing that you could put on
the web was a trailing mouse cursor so I
wanted to figure out how they did that I
would copy and paste those I can't leave
this up here it's gonna distract a lot
of you so I'll move on quickly but I
started building websites now I went
back and found one of the original sites
that I built this is like mm ish that I
built the first website I went and found
this on web page archive and I want to
show you just how terrible some of the
earliest JavaScript that I wrote in 2000
was I'm super embarrassed to admit I
have no idea why I was putting those
extra parentheses around those boolean
variables I I don't know what I was
thinking back at the time but I found
this code I was like oh this is gonna be
fun to show the whole world all the
mistakes that I made but you can notice
the other I was doing all kinds of like
fancy creating divs and layers and
dynamic stuff this was for a website
where my it was my uncle he had a home
building web site and he wanted to show
off the homes that he had available for
for sale he was a home builder and he
wanted to show off the homes he had
available for sale and I was doing
totally unnecessary it could have been a
totally done in a totally static website
but you know I learning JavaScript so I
want to do everything dynamic this was
like the the earliest version of what we
might call like a single page
application where we just switch in
different pages when you clicked on
stuff and then around that same period
of time this is a different website I
built a portfolio website for an artist
she did paintings and drawings and I was
really embarrassed to see that I was
using eval in this particular website
but then I realized actually I was doing
some research and I realized why I
needed to do eval and I thought this
might be an interesting point you'll
notice above it that I've got these
image 1 through image 9 erase at this
point in JavaScript history it did not
support multi-dimensional erase and I
needed a multi-dimensional array so you
know how I did it was I had ten nine or
ten separate JavaScript arrays and then
I eval with the index number to get to
one specific array to have the second
dimension of right I don't know how I
came up with that but somehow I was just
Hawking my way to some solution and
thankfully now obviously JavaScript does
support multi-dimensional arrays but
these were some of my earliest baby
steps into what would become a
profession for me building the web and
writing JavaScript to build the web I
moved on a few years later in my career
I graduate from college and I have a
career and I'm working at an agency and
I got the opportunity to build the
homepage for this regional airline in
the u.s. called Southwest Airlines it's
the first time they'd ever hired anybody
to do their own website and I was the
lead front-end engineer on this project
one of many high profile projects so I'd
really sort of arrived in my career like
I'm building stuff that millions of
people are going to get to see we were
given this project the designers had
built a you know designed everything
expected out we were given this project
three weeks before the Christmas break
and told me and three other engineers we
had to build this whole homepage in
three weeks and you'll notice at the
time this was like 2006 ish like late
2006 I think and so if you notice in
this we've got things like a calendar
widget we use the Yui calendar widget
this was brand new state of the art
there were JavaScript frameworks that
could give us widgets and a designer
dropped this into the design and then we
had to figure it out I remember we spent
quite a while like several days just
trying to hack through the code on this
Yui calendar widget to get it to disk
play the full month name instead of the
abbreviated month name or something
ridiculous like that we we didn't know
what we were doing but we're Hawking
through all this code trying to make it
work and two weeks into that three-week
period we're almost ready to get this
thing wrapped up and go on Christmas
break and they said oh by the way this
website needs to support Netscape 4 and
we're like wow there's no way we're
gonna make it this Yui calendar widget
work on an old browser like that we did
all kinds of hacky stuff like
conditional comments and hiding things
and we didn't get much of a Christmas
break that year that's for sure
so I was I was definitely working on the
real web as we might think of it today I
was using JavaScript frameworks and
components and things just like you were
do would do today and I do just like and
I did just like many developers did I
just drop this stuff in I copied and
pasted it off of some tutorial or some
documentation page and dropped it in and
then hacked my way to it I didn't really
know at this point what I was doing but
I'm somehow hateable ship a website that
millions of people were using for a
brief period of time about a year we
outgrew the capabilities of the web and
this agency had me build websites and
flash and one of the websites that I
spent quite a bit of time on was this
kid's website for a grocery store chain
in my part of the u.s. called h-e-b and
this was the HG buddy kids website built
a bunch of games and other stuff like
that
this entire website is built in flash
and I literally cannot even load this
same website onto my computer because I
have - the flash completely banned on
the computer so I had to load up like an
old VM just to get this screen shot
because the site is still there thirteen
years later it still says new site new
game they never touched it after I built
it and deployed it if you still have
flash you can go check out HD Bunny but
I was kind of cheating sort of cheating
because yes this was still web
programming but we couldn't really do
consistently cross-browser at that
moment in 2007-2008 we couldn't really
do consistently cross browse with the
things that the designers were coming up
with so flash was kind of this pressure
release it was a
that allowed us to have this kind of
consistent canvas to to paint things on
to so I spent a bit of time working in
flash now I'm saying she kind of with
some air coat air quotes because this
was actually tilt still technically web
programming this is an important part of
the web's history is that we went we did
flash and actually most of what we have
in html5 and even JavaScript is as a
direct result of things like flash they
invented ideas that we're still trying
to catch up to with the open web
platform so I'm not at all hating on
flash but it's certainly not something I
do anymore these days but for a brief
period of time this was a very important
part of my journey into figuring out how
to build and deploy to the web as a
platform and then you fast forward about
another year well into 2008 at this
point and my career had really become
all about the dollar signs but of course
I'm talking about jQuery like everybody
else Jake at the time jQuery just took
the took the web by storm and I was
fascinated by jQuery and this is
actually an important inflection point
for me because this was really the first
time that I it sparked a curiosity in me
I at this point had really just been
using things that people had provided to
me and not really curious about how or
why they work and for the first time I
saw something like jQuery and I'm
embarrassed to admit in 2008 I'd been
doing it for almost a decade and I
literally did not know that the dollar
sign was a valid character to show up in
a variable in JavaScript I was like what
is this magical dollar sign thing and I
had to go look it up and I was like oh
that's just a variable like X or a but I
dug into the jQuery source code and I
was tremendously curious about how they
did all this stuff with this keyword and
closures and and what opened up for me
at that moment was a curiosity about
JavaScript a language this was not
JavaScript a toy anymore this was
JavaScript a real language that could
solve real problems and for some reason
what she changed in me was I I thought
to myself if this is where my career is
headed I made these early bets on the
web and on JavaScript if this is where
my career is headed maybe I ought to
take it more seriously
maybe I ought to really understand how
this stuff works instead of just
dropping in components and widgets that
I've copied and pasted from other
websites so I pored over that source
code and tried to understand it and
build my own tools to do so and I was
around the same period of time that I
started working at open source and the
very first open source project I did
again sort of bridging from JavaScript
bridging from my Flash days back into
JavaScript because I built this thing
called flexor flexor was a cross-domain
Ajax polyfill if you will to replace xhr
to do cross the main Ajax at the time
when we didn't have cores we couldn't do
cross-domain Ajax I needed this for a
thing at work and I built it in the way
it worked was it used an invisible flash
file because flash had this ability to
cross the main request in a permissioned
way that the web didn't have at the time
so I have this JavaScript API that looks
like SHR and it bootstraps this
invisible flash and does cross the main
and I released it as source code this is
pre github I just released that I think
SourceForge or something but this was my
first open source hey I've learned
something about JavaScript and I now
understand how to use closures and and
build things and certainly after this in
2009 my next open source project that
I'm probably most well-known for was lob
GS dynamic script loader for performance
optimization of websites and this is
actually what got me started in
conference speaking was that I got
invited to speak about this particular
project it was in use by a number of big
sites including eventually sites like
Twitter and so I got got to start
talking about this stuff and you'll see
that I've made some progress in my Java
scripting at this point a little bit
more sophisticated than what I was doing
a decade earlier but I still didn't
fully understand JavaScript at the time
and I wanted to I wanted to take it
seriously and at the time there was this
great divide in what was available for
resources there's obviously lots of
websites out there that you can learn
things from but if you start talking
about trying to really learn JavaScript
take it seriously try to understand what
books do we have available this image
has been passed around forever as sort
of a joke about JavaScript because on
one side we have JavaScript the
definitive guide and
the other side we have JavaScript the
good parts and because there's a big
disparity in the size this must mean
javascript has a bunch of bad parts
that's the joke
right and so a lot of people have
laughed about this particular idea about
this big gap but for me almost
immediately what this what occurred to
me was this is like the gap between
trying to learn about some topic by
reading an exhaustive set of
encyclopedias first is trying to learn
about the same topic by reading the
Cliff's Notes in other words you have
one extreme where you have way too much
information and it's almost too much for
any one person to try to get in their
head and on the other end of the extreme
you have very brief summaries of
information that might get you passing a
test if you're crunching for a test but
certainly you would not be able to say
that you have any sort of mastery over
the material by simply reading the
Cliff's Notes and what I see here and
what pains me is this giant gap between
these two if I want to understand this
stuff and there's nothing there in the
middle for me to learn from and if it's
not there for me then it's not there for
the rest of us as well and this is what
led me this is one of the things that's
one of the problems that I poured over
and it's what led me to decide to
finally write the you know no js' book
series something I'm fairly well known
for now
the internet J's book series started out
being three books fifty pages of peace
that was my pitch to O'Reilly alright
three quick fifty page books and then
we'll be done it turned out there were
six books with eleven hundred pages
because it turns out there's a whole lot
more to say about JavaScript than I even
understood at the time and if if there
is no other way for me to describe what
this book series is it is my
documentation of my journey asking all
of the questions what is JavaScript
about how does it work why does it work
and I documented that in book form so
that other people don't have to go
figure that stuff out for themselves so
I sort of fixed the gap if you will I
created what was missing in between
hopefully a relatable discussion about
all of the different parts of JavaScript
not presented in an encyclopedic format
that doesn't work for most people but
presented in a converse
a tional tone it's almost as if you just
sitting down and saying hey why does
that thing do that here's why it does
that and here's how you can use that
that's been my goal and that launched my
teaching career and I now teach full
time so I travel all over the world I've
now spoken this is my 21st country in
six continents and I was about to hit my
seventh continent there's literally
going to be a conference in Antarctica
in January of next year and I was
accepted as a speaker and I was gonna go
and get my seventh continent badge
unfortunately had a personal conflict I
can't make it but I'm gonna get that one
day I'm gonna get that seventh continent
for sure but I'm tremendously privileged
to see such a broad range of our
community from speaking and from
teaching so my journey has been similar
to the one with NASA it's been marked by
lots of tiny baby steps I couldn't have
planned out my journey exactly the way
that I wanted and I wouldn't have been
able to even dream of where I am now if
I had been trying to plan to that so I
really just sort of stumbled through all
of these baby steps so one more history
lesson and this is of the JavaScript a
language but it is certainly not a
complete history lesson of the
JavaScript language the early days of
JavaScript this is some of the earliest
code that we know that we have it still
runs today there is a website that was
built in late 1995 very shortly after
javascript was a thing and this code was
written and deployed to the web and it's
still there you can go back and find
code like this in webpage archive this
was some of the earliest JavaScript that
was ever deployed publicly on the web
and it's interesting to me because it's
actually more sophisticated than I would
have expected for code that was
basically tend a prototype experimental
language code there's some
sophistication here that I wouldn't have
even expected at that time and then we
started to formulate more formal
JavaScript specification there were some
JavaScript specifications version 1 and
version 2 sort of fell on top of each
other but we started to get some very
interesting additions to the language
very early on this is like 97 98
timeframe we started to get some
JavaScript things that we know today
like for example he started to be able
to assign to the prototype of a function
and do the very earliest forms of what
we would eventually
all the prototypal class pattern in
JavaScript and then NES three we got
some huge things number most importantly
in es3 we got the ability to actually
use functions as expressions we got
closure in JavaScript and I would argue
that was the biggest inflection point in
the history of the language because it
became truly a first class programming
language at that moment we also got a
bunch of other things like try caches
and and exceptions and things like that
so there was a ton of things that
finally formalized in es3 now after he
s3 because he s3 was in 1999 after he s3
there was a set of proposed changes to
language that were quite radical and
they went by this name es 4 and this is
where in like 2003 2004 timeframe at
this point and there's a set of people
that are in the working group in tc39
that want to do this a whole bunch of
changes they want to add classes and
packages and types and all kinds of
stuff to javascript and there have this
proposal together with es 4 and then
there's another faction of people that
were very vehemently opposed to that
direction for javascript and they could
not agree and they fought back and forth
for months and years and they couldn't
agree and eventually one of the things
that they did to try to prove this was
they went and implemented that one of
the groups that was in favor of es 4
when an implemented and that's what
ActionScript 3 was was an implementation
of this ill-fated es 4 specification so
if you've ever written ActionScript 3
you actually wrote es 4 that was
JavaScript or at least what they wanted
JavaScript to be unfortunately this was
not to be they could never agree and
after a long prolonged period of
fighting they eventually gave up and
said this isn't going to work we're not
gonna be able to come to an agreement
here and we entered into what we would
disaffection aliy now referred to as the
dark ages of the web because around this
same period of time 2005 and 2006 is
when also the web platform began to
stagnate
not only was javascript not able to
progress but the greater web platform
was stagnating and famously folks at
microsoft said well they're not going to
need to be any more internet explorer
and they disbanded most of the Internet
Explorer team and they said we don't
need any new browsers we don't need it
there something is going to replace the
web
and it it came within that close of the
web dying at that time there was a long
period of time where nothing progressed
and we arguably saw this flourishing of
all these other things like flash and
Java and things like that because the
web had no answer for what people wanted
to do on that web delivery platform in
this same period of time that JavaScript
was stagnating with es4 there was
another proposal a lot of people think
it was the same it's actually a separate
proposal called Eve or X which was
basically XML for JavaScript and this
might look a lot familiar to you because
the revenge is that even though E for X
eventually died we got it back in the
form of JSX right because people have
really wanted to embed things like HTML
in their JavaScript so this one died and
I would argue it died a very
well-deserved justified death of
dysentery I'm glad that the JavaScript
did not pick up this particular form of
spec all right so finally they came back
together this is a full ten years later
we went from 1999 all the way to 2009
before they finally came back together
in this end all that big stuff that we
wanted to do and couldn't agree on let's
come up with a very small subset of
changes and the most notable of those
changes was strictmode
we really needed strictmode let's go
ahead and land es5 with a few extra
api's and basically strictmode and that
was the compromise in nineteen amin in
2009 to get javascript back on a track
of evolving after stagnating for an
entire decade also over that same period
of time we've now got the browser wars
that are raging and that's really good
and healthy for the web because we have
Chrome and Firefox and Internet Explorer
and Safari and they're all fighting
against each other but for the our
benefit they're all trying to progress
the web faster and progress the web with
more features and things like that and
then we went unfortunately another five
years 2015 before we could land
something like the next version of
JavaScript which was known as es6
this was another huge change set in many
ways it was basically the revenge of es
4 it was all the stuff that we really
wanted in ES 4 back in 2004 we had to
wait more than a decade to land it in
2050
all of these changes and many of you
have probably felt still today even
three or four years later the fatigue of
all of those changes landing all at once
and this is sort of the anti story of
lots of tiny baby steps because when you
have process breakdown and then things
that built up and they've built up and
they've built up and then you just throw
it all on people like throwing up all
over them and people don't know what to
do with it and we still have problems
today in JavaScript because people are
still trying to come to terms with what
all these things do it's great job
security for somebody like me who
teaches JavaScript but it's not healthy
for the web for us to be building up all
of this stuff and making no progress and
then all of a sudden having this huge
change set so in this time they decided
at this moment this was the last time
that JavaScript would build up a whole
bunch of changes for years and years and
then just dump it on the community
instead they decided to move to a year
based revision system they tried to
rename es6 to es 2015 they tried to tell
people stop calling it es6 I'm here to
tell you as somebody who had written a
book already at that point and published
it with the word he has six in the title
ah it's not called es 2015 I don't care
what they say
it's called es6 okay so stop calling at
es 2015 it's called es6
but after that then we started getting
yearly updates and these were much
smaller and much more self-contained in
ES 2016 we literally lightened to just
two tiny features we landed the star
star operator for exponentiation because
we always do that and then we add that
added array includes which is actually
one of my favorite features by the way
starting with es 2016 stop calling it
stupid stuff like es 7 it's not called
es 7 anymore it's called es 2016 okay I
still see people today writing blog post
saying es 7 I'm like get with the times
so he s 2017 came along the next year
and it's not es 8 it's es 2017 and we
landed one of the most favorite features
in all of JavaScript which is the async
await function and a whole bunch of
other things as well but we landed
async/await in ES 2017 last year in ES
2018 we landed async generators which is
like the lovechild between
sinc functions and es6 generators put
them together into one function and now
we have async generators sounds weird
but there's actually a very important
use case for that and again there's a
bunch of other little things that landed
but that was kind of one of the major
hallmark features and just a month or
two ago they voted on the final feature
set for es 2019 and I've got a piece of
code here we added some little features
like object up from entries which
nobody's going to use but the big one
was we finally resolved smouch gate
right it's not called smush it's called
array dot flat and then we also have
thought flat map so that's the big one
and also just a tiny little one which is
actually one of my favorite features in
all of JavaScript history on line 21 you
see I have a catch clause and I don't
need an error variable so there's no
catch definition there then we finally
landed that I've been wanting for that
for years and now we don't need to do
those unless have our lynchers
complaining about unnecessary error
variables so it's this repetitive thing
that you keep hearing from me that
javascript is now back on track to start
making lots of tiny baby steps and any
time and that it got off track from
using from making those baby steps
anytime the progress wasn't incremental
it was bad for the web and it was bad
for javascript and the best progress has
always been the progress that was
incremental this is a good and healthy
thing and it makes me wonder then well
what is the future going to be if we've
now caught ourselves up is the future
going to continue to be like this and
are we going to continue to have the
same kind of future that we want so
where are we going to be placing those
bets well here are some bets that were
made that I would arguably say have been
very bad bets along the way things that
basically said we don't need an open web
platform what we need is a future for
the web that is this closed proprietary
system and I'm gonna make a really
controversial statement and say I'm
going to predict it within the next
couple of years we're gonna say that
this was the worst bet of all the native
app store the worst bet of all against
the web Steve Jobs came out originally
launching the iPhone had said the web is
the future and then the very next year
he said no I can't make money on the web
so the native app store is the future
because that's where I can make money
and that turns out I think gonna be a
really bad bet
because what we have is better bets that
have been made since then like the open
web platform we have JavaScript and
html5 and CSS bed of all which is
progressive web apps a quick note on
progressive web apps by the way one of
the best parts about progressive web
apps is that they're solving finally
something the web platform itself hasn't
been able to do which is that I can be
reading something on my phone and get on
a plane and that web content is still
there the offline ability of the web is
a critical feature and I'm gonna make
this claim that might surprise you but
I'm gonna say every single web site in
existence I don't care what it does
every single web site needs to have at a
minimum a caching first Service Worker
so that it's offline capable because I
should not be reading your blog post and
then I get on a plane to fly over here
to Israel and all of a sudden I can't
read your blog post anymore that is
ridiculous and it is against what the
DNA of the web should be about so
progressive web apps and the
technologies underneath that umbrella
are giving us a future that is going to
be much better much better for the web
and much better for this sort of
collaborative work that we do together
one of the other things about
progressive web apps is that we're
getting away from this idea of
disability talking about what people
can't do and instead talking about what
people can do about their abilities
rather than their disabilities and I
would argue that this is one of the ways
that we are going to win against the
native app ecosystem because the web has
always had in its DNA to be accessible
first and we've been the ones that have
been screwing it up
but we have the opportunity to change
course we have the opportunity to make
better decisions and these technologies
are going to write a different sort of a
future one that embraces what people can
do rather than restricting them based on
what they cannot do and finally I think
what the web houses we have always had
the ability to embrace the idea of
incremental updates I have a game on my
phone that I love playing everytime it
updates about once every couple weeks
it's a hundred and nineteen megabyte
download which is not such a big deal
when I'm at home and I've got my
superfast Wi-Fi in the US but when I'm
here
abroad which I spend most of my time
traveling abroad I get QG internet
speeds guess how long it takes me to
download 100
nineteen megabytes over 2g speeds I'm
still waiting on the download for my
previous trip that's how long it takes
these are all fantastic things for the
future and I write I think they
represent great bets for the future of
the web think about something like the
International Space Station it was
famously this amazing collaboration
between the United States and Russia and
several other countries they came
together think about what that first
meeting was like they don't even use the
same system of measurement we've got the
empirical in the metric system how did
those scientists get together and figure
out that this thing fits together with
this thing it's an amazing story of open
collaboration and I will tell you that
open collaboration is the thing that has
always one you have to start open
you can't build something in isolation
and proprietary and then just sort of
whitewash it is open it has to start
open that's the only way that it's ever
worked and that's always been the best
bet throughout all of history not just
technology the open path is the one
that's always eventually won but here we
come to the question point for the rest
of my time with you and I know my time
is short but we come to this question
plain because JavaScript really is at a
fork just like in the proprietary versus
governmental base space technologies and
there's a fork happening and we're not
really sure and I'm not making a
political statement on which one is
right or wrong but it is undeniable that
there is a different future that's going
to happen now as they begin to fork and
I'm going to say that there's a
different future that's going to begin
to happen as JavaScript the language
begins to diverge more from JavaScript
that is a machine these two have been
the same for a long period of time but
they are beginning to diverge and
Brendan Eich who's just sort of peeking
around the corner saying what's going on
with my JavaScript language it's just
like if you had two spaceships that took
off from Earth and they were headed to
these distant galaxies for the first
several million years they would look
like they are flying in parallel they
look like they're flying towards the
same destination but eventually they end
up millions of light-years apart and the
problem that we have is when we think
about these two things on this same path
and we
only think myopically about what's
happening right now we can't see that
they're on slightly different paths that
millions of light years from now they're
going to be in entirely different
locations for a long time javascript has
been the same it's been able to serve
all of these different things that both
the language concerns and the machine
concerns but I'm arguing that we're
going to be heading to very different
galaxies and that might not be the web
that we want so the the future of what
the web is has always been incremental
and open but will that always be the
right way for the web to evolve or do we
need to have a different approach so
very quickly I want to talk to you about
the language versus the machine of
JavaScript these are a couple of things
that we know about JavaScript the
language first of all code is a form of
human communication and you can read
that because your brain understands
English and can understand communication
code is first and foremost a means of
communication it's not instructing the
computer and I actually think that
javascript is one of the best suited
languages in all of existence for you to
communicate your ideas it's called the
lingua franca of the web and by the way
if you don't know what that means you
should look it up lingua franca doesn't
just mean everywhere and you know
ubiquitous lingua franca means it's an
important bridge language between two
incompatible languages and JavaScript is
where a go programmer and a hostile
programmer that speak very different
ways of thinking can somehow figure out
a common way to communicate with each
other that's an important part of
JavaScript one of the most important
parts of JavaScript is that it was built
from the beginning to be multi-paradigm
not just that you could pick one or the
other but that you can pick all
different paradigms within the same
application I would argue that's one of
the reasons why JavaScript has become so
popular in states so popular is because
it has been so flexible and javascript
has also been declarative and it is
moving more and more in the direction of
declarative as a matter of fact most of
what es6 did was to move from the
imperative forms of programming more
towards the direction of declarative
programming and that favors more
readability and more understandability
and more maintainability for our code
this is a good thing and it's going to
continue to happen for the future it's
sign of maturity of the language also
JavaScript and really the bigger web but
definitely javascript says code that was
written back in 1995 still runs today in
the web and that's a good thing because
you can bet on JavaScript you can write
something and know that next week it's
not just going to break because some
browser decided they don't like that
javascript there was a time when people
thought the javascript was slow and
sloppy and buggy and inconsistent and
some of you may still adhere to some of
those old thoughts about the way things
were back in like 2004 please join us in
2019 that's not what javascript is today
that's not the status quo of the web we
have a fantastically consistent and
mature and constantly evolving ecosystem
of technologies and the language is
serving us in many great ways here's a
couple of quick things that are coming
down the pike likely hopefully probably
going to show up in JavaScript near you
if you're into class programming we're
getting a whole bunch of new features
out into the language that are gonna
allow you to communicate better with
your code things like class fields and
private fields and private methods those
are on the cost of of landing they
almost made it in there probably make it
in in the next year standard we have
optional chaining in other words instead
of having to check to see if a property
has been undefined before you access a
property on it now we can use the
question mark dot operator to just
access it and failsafe back to normal
readable numbers a tiny feature but one
of the things that I think will actually
help a lot of readability the ability to
put separators in your long number
literals like the underscore character
to separate out the digits and big int
maybe one of the biggest complaints
about JavaScript is that it has this one
single number type that's not able to
handle many of the important use cases
that have emerged on the web and we're
finally starting to evolve in a
direction of 64-bit numbers we now have
big int support that's at stage three
and almost about to land in Java scripts
already in several of your browsers so
big it represents the fact that
javascript is maturing in all of the
ways that people have needed it to
mature it is responding to those needs
so stop thinking the way you used to
about JavaScript that it's this weird
and inconsistent and behind sort of
system it's on the cutting edge and it's
moving forward and evolving so if you
think about how JavaScript has evolved
we're not just landing on the moon we're
talking about landing on Mars there's a
bright future with lots of steps ahead
of us
we've made a lot of progress already and
we've got a long way to go I'm not
betting against the future of JavaScript
I'm not worried at all that javascript
is gonna be around 20-30 years from now
I'm perfectly secure in knowing that I
have good job security investments in
JavaScript is going to continue to pay
off for any of the lifetime that I need
to worry about my career it has a bright
and vibrant future but it might be a
little bit different than some of us are
expecting because there is this other
direction this other tension that is
pulling javascript in this other
direction and for a while it was just
doing it within the constraints of
JavaScript and now it's starting to
break out of JavaScript and that is what
has me concerned we have the machine
side of JavaScript for many people have
said for many years that JavaScript is
the Assembly of the language i've always
balked at that I don't think that that's
the right way to think about JavaScript
as if javascript is it doesn't even
matter what it is it could might as well
just be ones and zeroes because we're
all gonna write in our other favorite
languages the DNA of the web is
inextricably linked to what javascript
is what it has been and what it will be
- forget about javascript the language
and say it's only just some target for
compilation from other languages is to
forget an entire important part of the
DNA of the web so I don't like thinking
about it as the assembly but there are
certainly some very important concerns
there's increased demands that have been
asked for JavaScript we want 3d gaming
and we want all of these sorts of things
that the language itself really wasn't
capable of doing and so we started
adding these features to JavaScript to
support that use case that really don't
even make sense
I mean I'm showing you like for example
proxy we added the proxy feature to
JavaScript back in es6 and while it's a
great and interesting feature none of
you will ever ever author a proxy
nobody's ever gonna write that code
that's gonna be code that is written for
you by a machine
compilers gonna write proxies for you
your frameworks gonna do proxies for
you're not gonna write this kind of
stuff
and that's okay but we've been
increasing the surface area of
complexity of JavaScript making more
JavaScript and more things to learn and
more things to go wrong and more things
to be abused and we've been doing it
because javascript is being pulled in
this other direction to service the use
case of the machine instead of the
author of the developer of the
communicator
we not only added proxy we've added
typed arrays again a very important
feature but none of you are gonna write
code to discover whether you are on a
little endian or big-endian system
that's just not a thing anybody on the
web is ever going to write code for so
this feature exists in JavaScript and it
has a surface area and it can be abused
by people that are trying to like break
in and create vulnerabilities to your
systems as a matter of fact this next
one shared memory and Atomics we now
have multi-threading capabilities in
JavaScript and I'd like to take credit
for that by the way because I stood up
on a stage for years saying we're never
gonna have multi-threading and as soon
as you say something's never going to
happen is guaranteed to happen so you
can thank me for that we now have
multi-threading but guess what this
amazing thing where we could now use
Atomics and shared array memory segments
between different threads of JavaScript
that was immediately pounced upon by
people trying to create security
vulnerabilities you might remember about
a year year and a half ago when there
was a vulnerability in the CPUs the
Spector and all those other bugs they
were exploiting bugs in JavaScript by by
creating high resolution timers with
shared memory segments so they had to
turn off this feature that they had
spent all these years trying to put in
because as soon as you out of feature
somebody's going to try to figure out
how to abuse that feature so there is a
real cost to expanding the surface area
of a language just to try to serve some
particular use case and it's that
question that I don't think we've been
asking ourselves as responsibly as we
should and of course after after we got
Atomics and shared memory and they took
this stuff away
well now you asked well we're not even
writing her code anymore right because
the code that runs in the way of his
code that's gone through a several
all transformation steps and webpack
babbles great because we can write nice
beautiful code like that and we can ship
really great code like that right that
must be better for the web now I'm not
down on transpilers there's certainly an
important part I welcome our new
transpiling overlords this is how we
move from trailing to leading in the web
that's a great thing but it is a shift a
seismic shift in the way that we deal
with the web because the code that is
running on the web doesn't look at all
like the code that was written anymore
and we're only creating more and more
separation and that's the part that I
wonder is going to hurt the future of
the web now some people say well the
solution to this is just source maps you
can still look at the original source
code yeah source maps are great I was
actually part of working on this when I
worked for Mozilla years ago the source
maps are great but there are problems
for example source maps don't work that
well with stack traces especially when
they're radically different languages
they don't warily work well for watch
expressions and other sorts of advanced
debugging and there's a bunch of other
little issues with them so they're not a
perfect solution they're just sort of a
temporary stopgap then we have other
systems like typescript and flow and
other things basically languages that
look like JavaScript but they've been
added other things to it and I get asked
all the time what do you think about
typescript I'm glad that typescript
exists I really genuinely am that for a
certain segment of our developer
population I think it makes complete
sense to be using typescript it solves
problems that I don't have in ways that
I don't like so I don't personally use
it but it's not a bad system I'm glad
that it exists except I'm not sure that
we're really counting the cost of
locking ourselves into a non-standard
system right now that doesn't seem like
a big cost but if you look back over the
history of technology every single time
you've locked yourselves into a closed
system it has turned out to be not a
great decision so I want us to be asking
these questions about the decisions that
we make we get so myopically focused on
all I got to do is ship the next
delivery of this code and we don't ask
what is that going to mean for my
codebase a year from now and five years
from now we've got we've talked about
adding macros to language this is a
really cool feature I love meta program
being able to write a macro that
transforms this is like an old example
transforming delet keyword so you have
stuff like that and what actually runs
in the browser is that this is like
babel to the whole new degree because
it's running inside of the JavaScript
engine on the fly it's rewriting the
code that's what a macro does it's gonna
be even harder to figure out what codes
running because it won't even be the
code that was shipped to the browser
it'll be code transforming itself in the
runtime there's a real cost involved in
those sorts of decisions and I'm not
sure anymore that that's the direction
we want to go
some of you know Tom Dale real famous he
runs he's one of the lead developers for
the ember framework Tom Dale wrote this
blog post about a year year and a half
ago called compilers of the new
frameworks and he put up this
interesting thesis which was the future
of the web is not all these compilers
like Babel the future is that you're
gonna I mean all these frameworks like
ember the future is basically that those
frameworks will become your language
that there will be like an ember
language or like a react language and it
will not at all
be you know restricted by what
JavaScript it is will evolve on its own
timeline with its own feature sets and
those compilers will just write all your
code for you so I got to thinking well
that's interesting if if the framework
authors can experiment with the future
of what web programming is about does
that mean that the rest of us can
experiment with it so I had this one
idea I wanted to write curried function
declarations functions that could accept
more than one input and I put this
proposal idea out there I said this
seems like it would work I've checked
the JavaScript grammar I think that it
would be compatible what are you
thinking I got several hundred responses
like that sounds really cool that'd be
great for functional programming let's
do that so I put out this message and I
said alright here's what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna fork one of the parsers and
just put up an experimental parser and
let's play with this and see what it
works and I immediately got all of these
you know thumbs up in the public people
are like this is great this is awesome
and then I got dozens of messages from
TC 39 members in my private message
stack saying my god no absolutely not
under no circumstances should you go
fork the parser and come up with your
own idea for what JavaScript should be
because we're too worried that you're so
popular they literally told me this your
that's a high-profile figure that if you
come up with an idea that's not
compatible with what we want now we'll
have a division in JavaScript don't make
a parser that does stuff that's
non-standard JavaScript so my takeaway
from this is it's okay if you work for
Microsoft or you work for one of the
famous frameworks it's okay for you to
experiment but us we don't get the right
to participate and to me that doesn't
sound like the open collaborative
systems that have always won for
creating a future where only the few get
to decide what's going to happen for the
future of our platform that is not a
healthy direction to move some ASM Jas
was a great step along the way we got a
s MJ s to be able to do faster more
performant JavaScript and of course the
next step was web assembly now I get
asked all the time what about web
assembly what do you think about web
assembly well I'm glad that web assembly
exists it represents a really important
answer almost a pressure-release valve
there are things that people want to do
in the web platform that don't make
sense to put into javascript so let's
give them some other way to do it from
another language and target the web
platform for their delivery that makes
complete sense and I'm hugely in favor
of that but the one question that I want
to ask is because this is what web
assembly looks like compiling it doesn't
even remotely look like the kind of code
most of us could read and understand so
we're creating an even further gap in
separation and this story of all these
things that we keep doing in the machine
the machine side of the equation or all
because we have real valid questions and
real valid use cases to solve but the
solutions that were coming up with we
come back to this one question what is
that going to mean for the future view
source of the web now I've said this
many times and I've been made fun of by
some of the popular kids in the
JavaScript community because they make
fun of this quaint idea that you could
do a view source and understand what the
web is about there's like oh that's
silly and stupid that's what we did back
in 2000 well I have news for you the web
exists because people did that the web
would not have survived if people
couldn't figure out how to learn the web
and what I'm worried about for the
future is that some new aspiring
developer right now he's like 10 or 11
he's interested in the web and a couple
of years from now when he goes to do a
view source of the web
instead of seeing some HTML and CSS and
JavaScript and being able to copy and
paste a mouse cursor now he's going to
have some go and some rust and some PHP
and some JavaScript and half a dozen
other languages that are all mixed
together in a completely nonsensical way
and that's gonna be we're gonna say
that's the best future for the web
because it's so much more performant it
can do all of these other things and
we're gonna forget that people need to
be able to onboard to the web people
need to be able to learn and understand
and debug the web so are those futures
that were painting with machine
JavaScript really the future that we
want to get is it worth the cost I don't
have the answer for that question but I
don't think that question is being asked
for a long time the alternate title for
this talk by the way was a tale of two
Java scripts for a long time the tale of
two Java scripts has been a good nice
fairy tale with a good happy ending and
so far it's been a very good bet but I
want to ask where are you placing your
bet for the future are you placing your
bet on the divergence of these
technologies that makes it harder for us
to come together and collaborate or are
you placing your bet on ways that makes
it easier for us to collaborate because
the open collaboration is the thing that
has always won and if we give that up
far too easily because we want the the
new hot plugin and babble or whatever
that decision is then that we may not be
creating that future that we want let me
look back 10 or 20 years ago with
nostalgia remember when the web worked
remember when people could learn and
onboard to the web I don't want that
future so I want you to begin asking
these questions as you make the
technology decisions within your own
companies again I don't have those
answers I'm not trying to tell you
you're wrong but I don't think you're
asking those questions enough I don't
think you're dealing with that
particular responsibility to the weight
that it house thanks very much for
listening to these thoughts
you